bonjour et bienvenue sur public sénat
pour votre traditionnelles questions
d'actualité nous sommes ici salle des
conférences
à deux pas de l'hémicycle ou dans
quelques instants vous aurez le droit
évidemment à cette question d'actualité
dominé ces derniers temps par un
contexte politique est très difficile
pour le gouvernement et pour une
ministre en particulier mishna alliot
marie qui a toujours affaire à cette
affaire de son voyage en tunisie et de
son coup de fil qu'elle aurait eu avec
le président ben ali l'ancien président
de tunisie
ce matin il y avait une audition
commission des affaires étrangères
michèle alliot marie était auditionné et
bien le parti socialiste et l'ensemble
de la gauche a décidé de boycotter cette
audition nous nous expliquerons avec
jean pierre bel le président du groupe
socialiste
ici au sénat qui viendra sur notre
plateau après les questions d'actualité
pour s'expliquer sur cette position du
groupe du parti socialiste et je vous
propose tout de suite de rejoindre
l'hémicycle où l'on eût art est en train
de rentrer le vice président du sénat
est en train de rejoindre l'hémicycle
est tout de suite je vous laisse avec
les questions d'actualité on se retrouve
dans une heure pour on refait la séance
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports et porte sur la récente grève
qui a secoué les ports de notre pays
monsieur le secrétaire d'état comme l'a
justement et est gravement souligner
notre collègue louis
avant-hier au cours du débat sur les
infrastructures de transport aujourd'hui
le premier port français n'est ni
marseille ni le havre c'est anvers
la modernisation des ports français qui
doit faire face à la concurrence
acharnée des ports européens et mondiaux
est un enjeu essentiel du développement
économique futur de la france ce constat
est à l'origine d'une réforme profonde
de notre système portuaire qui a abouti
à l'adoption de la loi du 4 juillet 2008
saluée dans son rapport public annuel
par la cour des comptes présidée par
monsieur migaud rappelons qu'auparavant
les ports français étaient soumis à un
régime datant de 1967
aujourd'hui ce processus de
modernisation et dangereusement remis en
cause par une série de grèves de la part
des personnels portuaires
ce conflit social né du refus de
certains de contribuer équitablement à
l'effort national sur les retraites met
en péril des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises 215 milles sur les seuls
départements d'implantation des ports
qui font face à des difficultés
d'approvisionnement ainsi que les
augmentations de coûts de transport et
de stockage dramatique
en ces temps de reprise fragile de
l'activité économique dans mon
département de loire atlantique
le terminal fruitier à déplorer au mois
de janvier une diminution de son trafic
de 93% par comparaison à janvier 2010 et
une baisse du trafic conventionnel de 30
mille tonnes a été observé sur la même
période
dans les autres domaines malgré
l'annoncé récente d'une suspension de la
grève les dommages causés à l'économie
par ces interruptions de travail font
craindre une d irak dégradation
irréversible de l'image de nos peurs et
une fille née à détournement des trafics
vers des ports concurrents plus fiable
ce qui est d'ores et déjà le cas pour le
grand port de marseille
mais question se porteront donc sur
trois points précis pourriez-vous nous
assurer que la réforme portuaire
sera bien appliquée à son terme quelle
est la position du gouvernement sur
l'accord du 27 novembre dernier qui
devait permettre aux 5000 agents de
partir quatre ans avant l'âge légal de
retraite à raison de la pénibilité des
tâches
qu'en est-il réellement de cette
pénibilité au moment où un rapport de la
cour des comptes évoque les conditions
particulièrement avantageuses dont
bénéficient certains salariés
monsieur thierry mariani secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports va vous
répondre
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
sénateur andré trillard vous connaissez
bien cette quête cette question puisque
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé en
tant que sénateur de loire atlantique
vous pouvez voir tous les dégâts comme
vos collègues des bouches du rhône
d'autres départements que peut faire
aujourd'hui cette grève
à l'image des ports est à l'image de
notre pays alors pour répondre très
précisément en vaut trois questions
qu'est-ce qu'on compte faire sur la
réforme portuaire nous la mènerons
jusqu'à son terme cette réforme
portuaire vous le savez a été décidé
dans l'intérêt de notre pays pour
récréer une réelle compétitivité pour
nos ports nous mènerons cette réforme
jusqu'à son terme et nous sommes dans la
dernière étape
deuxième question est ce que quand est
il de l'accord du 27 octobre dernier
je me permets de faire un bref rappel de
chronologie les les organisations
professionnelles et le patronat avait
commencé à discuter des questions de
prise en compte de la pénibilité
entre temps vous le savez la loi sur les
retraites et bien été voté au sénat et à
l'assemblée est en réalité aujourd'hui
on a une loi qui s'applique à tous les
français qu'ils soient travailleurs
portuaires agriculteurs ou qui
s'applique à tous les français et la loi
est très claire à la pénibilité peut
être reconnue mais pour une durée de
deux ans que quelle est la position du
gouvernement d'abord d'abord
l'accord du 27 l'accord du 27 octobre
que vous évoquez est ce qu'il a été
signée réponse non excusez-moi je mets
au défi qui que ce soit dans cet
hémicycle de montrer un accord signé le
27 octobre
mais soyons honnêtes et est-ce qu'il ya
eu des discussions entre les partenaires
sociaux et une partie des employeurs oui
sauf que il manquait un troisième
partenaire qui n'avait pas donné son
accord excusez du peu
c'est l'état puisque c'est l'état qui
paye et et en l'occurrence il manquait
un accord pour mettre 140 millions à la
caisse pour financer cet accord
donc cet accord à ces discussions bien
eu lieu mais au coeur aucun accord n'a
été signé
enfin quel est l'enjeu aujourd'hui quel
est l'enjeu aujourd'hui est ce que oui
ou non en accord de travailleurs
portuaires un départ à la retraite à 58
ans alors qu'on vient de proposer à tous
les français désormais d'appliquer la
loi c'est-à-dire 62 ans
la réponse est claire oui à la
pénibilité oui dans le cadre de la loi
et oui à une application de la loi pour
les égales pour tous les français nous
avons tendu la main en proposant une
pénibilité de deux ans conformément à la
loi les négociations je vous le signale
on se déroule en ce moment et je pense
et j'espère qu'on arrivera à un accord
c'est l'intérêt des ports français c'est
l'intérêt de notre pays et c'est aussi
l'intérêt des travailleurs portuaires
bien sûr
la parole est maintenant un autre
collègue jean-pierre chevènement pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole
oui ma question s'adresse à monsieur
misé transports eurostar a commandé le 3
décembre 2010 à siemens dit rami ce2 400
m à motorisation répartie
cette commande contrevient aux règles de
sécurité qui prévalent dans le tunnel
sous la manche qui impose des motrices
en extrémité des trains pour permettre
en cas d'incendié transformateurs
l'évacuation à coup sûr des passagers
par des portes ménagers à cet effet à
l'intérieur du tunnel intervalle de 4
100 m
le choix d'eurostar et en plus étonnant
qu'il s'agit d'une filiale à 55% de la
sncf alstom a déposé un recours devant
la commission intergouvernementale
franco-britannique est devant la
commission européenne
mais question sont les suivantes je me
dise pourquoi at on laissé eurostar
commandé un train de l'autoriser par la
réglementation en vigueur
pouvez vous confirmer que les règles
écrites et ne seront pas modifiées sans
que des études préalables est attesté
que les trains dans les moteurs sont
placées sous les water sur les voitures
passagers
ce qu'on appelle train à motorisation
répartie n'entraîne aucune aggravation
des conditions de sécurité dans le
tunnel
deuxièmement vont nous mesurer les
conséquences industrielles pour alstom
et ses sous-traitants de ce contrat
confié à siemens dans des conditions qui
font d'ailleurs l'objet de recours à la
commission européenne et devant la
justice britannique comme je viens de le
dire
selon mes informations la commande
d'eurostar représente pour alstom
transport une perte d'un an et demi de
production soit 13 cents emplois sur un
total de huy 8800 en france sans compter
les 4200 entreprises sous-traitantes qui
emploient 27000 personnes dans cette
filière
l'ouverture du marché français à la
concurrence s'est traduite par une
baisse significative de la production
réalisée en france 2 79% il y a dix ans
à 62 % aujourd'hui la concurrence
implique me semble-t-il le respect de
certaines règles notamment l'occurrence
dans le domaine de la sécurité
troisième question quelles sont les
chances de voir le marché allemand la
très grande vitesse
s'ouvrir à la filière ferroviaire
française quatrième question enfin quel
signe fort du point de vue de la
politique industrielle
le gouvernement français a nantes il
donnait pour assurer au ferroviaire
français l'une des rares industries a
dégagé encore un solde commercial
excédentaire des conditions de
concurrence normale et équitable si
monsieur thierry mariani secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports vous répond
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
ministre à part de risque use m'en
excuser moi j'avoue que la situation est
un peu paradoxale la plupart d'entre
nous sont 100 élus qu'est-ce qui se
passerait dans une commune si on passait
à un appel d'offres quand on choisit si
l'entreprise puis qu'en dise une fois
qu'on a choisi l'entreprise
on va vérifier si les règles et c'est
bien respectée et c'est un peu ce qui se
passe effectivement dans la sphère que
vous dénoncez lorsque la société
eurostar en effet fait part de son
intention de signer un contrat avec
siemens pour l'achat de rames à grande
vitesse afin de renouveler une partie
des trains empruntant le tunnel sous la
manche
comme vous l'indiquez les rames
commandées qui serait doté d'une
technologie à motorisation répartie ne
sont pas autorisés actuellement à
emprunter le tunnel sous la manche
du fait des interrogations qui demeurent
sur cette technologie qui n'a pas été
prévu lors de la mise en service du
tunnel sous la manche en particulier au
regard des risques d'incendié je vous
rappelle que le 11 septembre 2008 il y
avait eu un incendie dont chacun se
souvient des conséquences sous ce fameux
tunnel sous la manche
tirant les enseignements d'accidents
parfois dramatiques dont celui que
j'évoquais le gouvernement français est
particulièrement attentifs et exigeants
sur les questions de sécurité afin que
les transports ferroviaires restent sous
le tunnel sous la manche comme ailleurs
particulièrement exemplaire
la france a donc demandé officiellement
dans le cadre de la commission
intergouvernementale que des études de
sécurité portant notamment sur
l'aptitude des trains à motorisation
répartie à circuler sous le tunnel soit
engagé préalablement à toute évolution
des règles de sécurité
ces études sont actuellement pilotée par
la commission intergouvernementale
franco-britannique autorités qui est
responsable de la sécurité dans le
tunnel sous la manche
l'avis technique a été demandé aux
experts en clair c est ce que les trains
allemands qui ont été choisis répondre
ou non aux normes de sécurité
on attend ses réponses courant mars
donc on attend donc plus que quelques
semaines ce n'est qu'à l'issue de cette
démarche qu'il sera possible de statuer
sur la possibilité d'autoriser ces
nouveaux matériels voilà je crois qu'il
faut pas s'interdire de faire évoluer
les règles de sécurité en vigueur dans
le tunnel notamment pour tenir compte
des améliorations permise par les
progrès de la technique mais toute
évolution des règles de sécurité doit se
faire à niveau de sécurité équivalent ou
d'amélioration bref quand certains de
nos amis allemands nous explique qu'il
s'agit de protectionnisme je les répéter
aux ministres allemands
il s'agit avant tout de faire en sorte
que dans ce tunnel les règles de
sécurité que nous avions émises en
commun soient respectées par l'ensemble
des partenaires si le xiiie s les
respecte nous nous opposerons pas au
marché si le train siemens ne répond pas
aux conditions de sécurité je ne vois
pas comment ce marché pour être passé le
remercie la parole est maintenant un
autre collègue le président jean arthuis
pour le groupe de l'union centriste que
le président madame messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé de la santé la loi
hôpital patients santé territoires
s'efforce de répondre à l'insuffisance
de présence médicale dans un certain
nombre de territoires et pour y répondre
elle a imaginé un contrat d'engagement
de service public au terme duquel des
étudiants en médecine à partir de la
deuxième année peuvent se voir rémunérés
à raison de 1200 euros par mois à
condition de s'engager à exercer dans un
territoire où il ya manifestement une
insuffisance de présence médicale le
ministre ce dispositif a du mal à
s'enclencher
parce que subsistent
deux inquiétudes la première c'est que
la régulation se perd au plan national
et qu'un étudiant souhaitant exercer
dans le département de la mayenne alors
qu' il est à la faculté danger ne
signera pas la convention parce qu'il a
peur d'être nommé dans d'autres
départements hors de la région
donc il ya manifestement un besoin de
communication pour dissiper ce
malentendu et à l'intérieur de chaque
région
subsiste un doute sur l'affectation qui
sera décidé au moment où cet étudiant
sera diplômé médecin je pense qu'il
serait bon que dès le moment où le
contrat est conclu c'est à dire la
deuxième année et bien ce jeune puisse
est orienté vers le territoire qu'il a
choisi faute de quoi je vous mets en
garde monsieur le ministre il risque d'y
avoir une ratée dans l'enclenchement de
ce dispositif d' oncle je souhaite que
l'on puisse territorialisée de tels
engagements et faire le pari de la
réussite en permettant un jeune de
savoir dès la deuxième année s'il en a
fait le choix
quel sera le territoire au sein duquel
il pourra exercer
lorsqu'il sera diplômé je vous remercie
monsieur xavier bertrand ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la santé vous
répond merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le ministre je crois à
l'incitation pour relever le défi de la
démographie médicale tous ceux qui
voudraient mettre en place la coercition
l'obligation se heurte au principe même
de l'exercice libéral de la médecine
sauf que sauf que il faut vraiment
donner toutes ses chances à l'incitation
et ne pas avoir des dysfonctionnements
comme ceux que vous évoquez parce
qu'effectivement de faire preuve de bon
sens sur le terrain cet interdit pour
personne et sur les sujets que vous
évoquez oui les outils existent mais il
faut tout simplement utiliser ces outils
avec un maximum de bon sens et un
recherche d'efficacité une recherche
d'efficacité de résultats
c'est le rôle notamment je le dis des
ars et directeurs généraux des ars
j'ai regardé dans une région comme la
vôtre il n'est pas normal monsieur le
ministre
il n'est pas normal qu'aucun contrat
n'ait pu être signés alors qu'il ya une
demande locale une demande qui les
mènent pas seulement des élus mais qui
émane également très logiquement deux
jeunes qui souhaitent bénéficier de ce
contrat sur la base du volontariat
personne ne les oblige à signer mais il
est vrai quand même que les moyens mis
sur la table
en vertu des textes je pense que ça
répond à l'enjeu
sauf que derrière il ne faut pas leur
compliquer la vie
il faut pas leur a donné une absence de
lisibilité à savoir que si on leur dit
qu'ils vont s'installer à tel endroit
ils veulent tout simplement pouvoir
s'installe à tel endroit et ne pas être
déplacés alors à qui revient cette
responsabilité je le dis aux directeurs
généraux des ars
j'aurai l'occasion avant la fin du mois
avec nora berra de les revoir et de
repasser très clairement des consignes
parce que vous le dites pour votre
région pour votre département
je suis élu d'une région et antoine
lefèvre ne me démentira pas qui connaît
le plus faible taux de médecins
généralistes en france en une région
coincée entre l'ile-de-france est la
région nord pas de calais et ces sujets
là ne relève pas seulement de certains
départements dont on parle bien souvent
c'est un sujet général nous avons mis en
place des outils
il faut tout simplement les utiliser
avec discernement et bon sens c'est ce
que je vais donner à nouveau comme
consigne parce que la question de la
démographie médicale
c'est un défi que nous avons relevé ça
ne sert à rien d'être dans les positions
idéologiques je veux du pragmatisme
c'est ce que nous allons faire
merci la parole est maintenant un autre
collègue yves krattinger pour le groupe
socialiste je vous demande de l'écouter
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre depuis 2007
nous constatons un affaissement des
services publics de l'état dans les
territoires
je donnerai ici trois exemples dans
l'éducation nationale
il y aura cette année 16000 suppressions
de postes
malgré une augmentation de 62 mille
élèves cette politique provoque une
dégradation sans précédent des
conditions de formation des jeunes tout
particulièrement pour ceux qui
rencontrent des difficultés
une note alarmante du centre d'analysé
stratégique classe la france en dernière
position pour le taux d'encadrement
parmi les 34 pays de l'osce et des oeufs
nous avons seulement 6,1 enseignants
pour 100 jeunes en formation de la
maternelle à l'université
et encore ce sont les chiffres de 2007
c'est très alarmant dans l'école
primaire pour l'apprentissage de la
lecture de l'écriture et du calcul il
est impossible dans ces conditions de
personnaliser les parcours est de tenir
compte de la diversité des élèves c'est
l'avenir de la jeunesse de france qui se
trouve hypothéquée
deuxième exemple les hôpitaux les
réductions budgétaires entraînent des
suppressions de postes qui génère la
saturation des urgences les difficultés
d'entretien des locaux et du matériel
la médecine à plusieurs vitesses la
qualité des services hospitaliers
l'égal accès aux soins pâtit lourdement
de vos orientations le monde hospitalier
tire la sonnette d'alarmé mais vous
ignorez le ressenti des soignants des
patients et des familles
c'est la santé des français qui est en
danger troisième exemple la sécurité
citoyens policiers et gendarmes
partagent la même inquiétude quant à la
diminution des effectifs vont ruse sur
la liste at sur les statistiques de la
délinquance ne peuvent masquer les
suppressions de postes et de brigade et
leurs conséquences l'éloignement de la
police et de la gendarmerie des
populations qu'elles sont censées
protéger c'est la sécurité des citoyens
qui n'est plus assurée monsieur le
premier ministre
les élections cantonales des 20 et 27
mars suscite dans les territoires de
nombreux débats sur ces problèmes
c'est une échéance que vous escamoter
les enseignants les personnels
hospitaliers les gendarmes sont parmi
les soldats de la république
ils sont au service de l'égalité devant
la gravité de la situation
acceptez-vous un moratoire dans le non
remplacement d'un départ en retraite sur
deux dans ces services essentiels à la
vie de nos concitoyens
merci monsieur françois baroin ministre
du budget des comptes publics de la
fonction publique et de la réforme de
l'état vous répond monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur krattinger à votre
question acceptez ou un moratoire la
réponse est non pourquoi parce que cette
révision générale des politiques
publiques a un sens
un objectif à une méthode s'inscrit dans
un calendrier le sens c'est oui et nous
l'assumons moins de fonctionnaires mais
mieux payés
kar kar kar ce qui constitue le principe
de l'application et de la déclinaison du
non remplacement du départ d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux c'est la
redistribution sous forme de
bonification indiciaire qui a permis de
redistribuer près de 2 milliards allant
chambre des fonctionnaires de notre pays
ce qui représente une moyenne de 800
euros par agent et permettez moi de vous
dire dans un pays comme le nôtre
si cette réforme n'avait pas été
acceptée elle ne serait pas passé la
première vague a permis de supprimer
cent mille postes
la deuxième boîte permettra de supprimer
nous reviendrons d'ici la fin de la
législature au même niveau que le nombre
de fonctionnaires que nous avions en
1990 et qui de sérieux peut dire que le
pays ne fonctionnait pas puisque vous
étiez aux affaires
alors je vous renvoie le compliment et
je vous renvoie à votre responsabilité
vous avez pris des exemples qui ne sont
pas forcément pertinent parce que il ya
un effet de ciseaux ou liées à
l'évolution démographique et tout cela
est maîtrisé jouer au site et deux
autres exemples l'un en votre qualité
d'élu local
il y à une mutualisation par exemple les
services de contrôle de légalité à
l'intérieur de la préfecture qui passe
par des suppressions de postes mais qui
permet de renforcer cette mission de
service public à la destination des
collectivités territoriales un deuxième
exemple qui vous fera peut-être moins
sourire parce qu'il est encore plus
spectaculaire
la direction générale des douanes dont
j'ai la charge l'autorité la tutelle a
vu réduire son nombre d'agents jusqu'à
dix-huit mille pratique le non
remplacement d'un départ sur deux a plus
de 60% c'est à dire que c'est l'un des
ministères et une des directions qui
apporte le plus et cette année j'ai
présenté comme ministre du budget les
résultats de la douane nous n'avons
jamais eu de meilleurs résultats depuis
15 ans ce qui montre qu'on peut réduire
la voilure réduire le périmètre
permettre d'augmenter le traitement de
nos agents et avoir des résultats dans
l'émission service public qui leurs sont
allouées en augmentation
je vous remercie la parole est à notre
collègue jean claude danglot pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
les sénateurs du parti de gauche et
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur eric
besson ministre chargé de l'industrie de
l'énergie et de l'économie numérique
il y à plus d'un an les sénateurs de
gauche mené une bataille parlementaire
historique pour sauver le service public
postal dans tout le pays les voix
s'élever les manifestations d'usagers et
de salariés se multiplier contre le
projet de privatisation de l'entreprise
publique
le peuple a demandé un référendum plus
de deux millions de personnes ont
exprimé leur opposition votre projet
vous avez avec votre majorité
insulter les organisateurs de la boucle
votation citoyenne et les nombreux élus
locaux qui les ont soutenus vous avez
nier la portée de ce mouvement et vous
l'avez méprisés en parlant de
manipulation vous avez manoeuvrer
jusqu'au bout pour arracher une majorité
au sénat
et pour cela vous avez tenté de rassurer
sur les conséquences du changement de
statut
votre prédécesseur ministre le ministre
ausy a même sorti de son chapeau
le concept un privatisable aujourd'hui
les crimes d'hier se confirme le
précédent contrat de présence postale
2007-2010 validé plus de 6000 fermeture
de bureaux de poste et 6600 suppressions
d'emplois vous nous avez illusionner
avec les 17000 points contacts mais en
réalité dans mon département le pas de
calais entre 2005 et 2010 8 116 emplois
ont été supprimés
pour 2011 on prévoit déjà 100 postes de
facteurs et 59 guichetiers en moins
alors qu'en 2008 on comptait 115
remplaçant aujourd'hui on est en encore
de 23 pour tout mon département le
rythme effréné des suppressions de
bureaux de poste ou leur transformation
simple le point contact laissant
orphelins les pentes chez de territoire
sans même que les élus locaux soient
concertés ou averti lé pire encore
le président de la république s'est
livré dans le cher à une véritable
insulte envers les maires ruraux
jusqu alors proposé de distribuer le
courrier eux-mêmes s'ils ne sont pas
contents les usagers ne sont pas les
seules victimes de cette politique
assassine les coupes claires de
personnel des restructurations tout
azimut les pressions de la direction
entraîne une souffrance au travail
inacceptables avec les 70 suicides
enregistrés sous vos yeux se déroule un
véritable drame humain et vous ne
pourrez pas dire que vous ne saviez pas
un regard des conséquences délétères de
la privatisation de france télécom
j'en termine avec ma question nous vous
demandons donc dans les plus brefs
délais de convoquer le pdg de la poste
jean-paul bailly à qui vous avez
retrouvé votre confiance car il doit
rendre des comptes et s'engager à
revenir à la conception dire du service
public à l'égard des personnels et des
usagers
merci monsieur eric besson ministre
chargé de l'industrie de l'énergie
l'économie numérique vous répond merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur jean claude danglot
contrairement à ce que vous suggérez
nous n'avons pas affaibli la poste nous
avons consolidé la poste et nous lui
avons les données les moyens de
s'adapter à deux éléments que vous
connaissez un la concurrence d'internet
elle est réelle n'est pas le fait du
gouvernement et de l'ouverture à la
concurrence
la loi du 9 février 2011 qui a porté
changement du statut à renforcer le
caractère de grande entreprise publique
de la poste elle dispose que de capital
de la poste doit obligatoirement être
détenus par des personnes publiques
s'est figé dans la loi donc il n'ya pas
de prétendus privatisation comme vous le
suggérez qu'un actionnaire privé ne peut
pas entrer au capital de la poste
par ailleurs et de façon concomitante la
loi permet de procéder à une
augmentation de capital
et vous savez que nous allons apporter
deux milliards 700 millions d'euros
d'argent public à la poste
comment pouvez vous suggérer que l'état
se désengage
par ailleurs la loi sanctuarisent quatre
missions de service public de la poste
aux missions auxquelles vous êtes tous
nous sommes tous très attachés
d'abord le transport du courrier la
distribution de la presse
le livret a et l'aménagement du
territoire à cet égard sur l'aménagement
du territoire il y avait fait allusion
il est expressément indiqué et c'est la
toute première fois que la poste doit
maintenir ses dix sept mille points de
contact sur le territoire
c'est pas une illusion c'est une réalité
où est la prétendue disparition du
service public
enfin la postière les engagements que
l'on attend d'une grande entreprise
publique et nous y sommes
particulièrement attentifs
d'abord ses engagements envers ses
agents la poste recrute près de 4000
personnes chaque année
ça n'est pas tout à fait rien et le
président de la poste auquel vous avez
fait allusion suis personnellement il a
en plus créé une petite équipe pour cela
les conditions de travail et de stress
au travail
eu égard à un certain nombre de drames
individuels que vous avez noté à juste
titre et que nous suivons avec beaucoup
d'attention la poste respecte aussi ses
engagements envers ses clients
elle continue à moderniser ses bureaux
de poste et améliorer la qualité de
service par exemple en réduisant les
files d'attentes
enfin ses engagements envers les
territoires
le sénat est très vigilant à juste titre
cherche points et 70 millions d'euros
que l'état apporte dans le cadre du
prochain contrat de présence postale
territoriale vont y contribuer voilà
monsieur le sénateur nous sommes tous
très attachés au service public de la
poste
mais ce gouvernement et la majorité
entendent lui donner les moyens de son
développement et sa modernisation
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue jacques gauthier pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
mais c'est le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre d'état monsieur
alain juppé mise la défense et des
anciens combattants
mais c'est le ministre d'état en 2008 le
stationnement en métropole de nos forces
armées étaient principalement orientée
vers le nord-est du territoire et
s'étendait sur 471 commune différente
avec des déploiements diversifié
hétérogène de nos formations militaires
qui disposaient chacune de soutien
individualisé à l'application des
conclusions du livre blanc sur la
défense nationale et la sécurité
et dans le cas de la loi de
programmation militaire le gouvernement
a donc engagé une profonde réforme de
notre politique de défense
ambitieuse et difficile car elle touche
au coeur des hommes et des femmes de
votre ministère mais aussi au coeur de
nos territoires
rappelons que la révision du format des
armées
la mutualisation des services et la
création des bases de défense génère des
économies qui bénéficient directement
d'une part à la revalorisation de la
condition des personnels mais aussi à
l'équipement de nos forces
ces restructurations de la défense
concerne aussi naturellement la
réduction des emprises puisqu'il est
prévu que plusieurs dizaines de terrains
et bâtiments seront cédés sur la période
2009 2014
dans le cas d'une réflexion globale
adaptée à chaque territoire avec un
effort particulier d'accompagnement pour
les zones concernées
chacun de nous ici c'est combien
l'implantation d'une unité militaire
rime avec bassin de vie pour nos villes
le département et nos régions mais
chemise d'état vous étiez la semaine
dernière à cambrai pour la fermeture de
la base aérienne
pourriez vous nous préciser quels sont
les accompagnements de reconversion et
de redynamisation économique qui sont
prévues pour limiter l'impact de ces
fermetures pour nos collectivités
locales mais aussi
pour préserver l'avenir de nos communes
je vous remercie merci la parole et tout
monsieur alain juppé ministre d'état
ministre défense et des anciens
combattants
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jacques gauthier comme vous
venez de le rappeler monsieur le
sénateur nos armées se sont engagés
depuis 2009 dans une transformation
radicale c'est la plus grandes réformes
accomplies depuis plusieurs décennies
elle aboutira d'ici 2015 à la fermeture
de 82 unités
22e régiment onze bases aériennes une
base aéronavale six centres de la dg à
ces fermetures ne sont pas une fin en
soi
leur objectif c'est bien évidemment de
rendre notre outil de défense plus
compacte plus réactif et plus
opérationnel et comme vous l'avez dit
les économies réalisées seront tu pour
la plus grande partie redéployés au
profit de l'équipement de nos troupes
on peut déjà constater un afghanistan
comme vous l'avez vous même je crois que
cet équipement s'est beaucoup améliorée
depuis quelques années nous sommes
parfaitement conscients que la fermeture
d'une unité sur un territoire peut être
un véritable traumatisme économique et
sociale et donc nous avons prévu un
budget de 320 millions d'euros sur la
période 2009 2014
pour accompagner ces transformations
vous avez cité la base de cambrai j
étais la semaine dernière à l'invitation
du sénateur jacques legendre du député
maire de cambrai eh bien nous avons
signé un contrat de redynamisation de
site de défense dans lequel l'état
apporte 14 millions d'euros les
collectivités territoriales à peu près
la même somme ce qui va nous permettre
de créer un outil de formation de 170
apprentis et un centre de liquidation
des factures qui emploie 420 personnes
je pourrais donner d'autres exemples de
ces reconversions par exemple à toulouse
francazal la mise en place d'un
aérodrome civil pour compenser la
fermeture de l'aérodrome militaire ou la
création d'internats d'excellence à
sourdun noyau ou montpellier
voyez donc que nous avons prévu cet
accompagnement qui prend une autre forme
dans les bassins d'emploi les plus
fragiles le ministère de la défense vous
le savez cède ses emprises aux communes
pour un euro symbolique et sur les 200
emprises qui seront concernés sur la
période 2
1009 à 2014 à peu près la moitié seront
éligibles à cette procédure de gratuité
pourrait terminer en signalant qu'il
faut accompagner la territoire il faut
aussi accompagner les personnels et nous
sommes très vigilants pour faciliter les
mutations des personnels militaires et
civils qui doivent changer d'affectation
50000 mutation entre 2009 et aujourd'hui
ou pour faciliter leur reconversion
j'ai fait de la réussite de cette
réforme ma priorité je n'y parviendrait
que si l'ensemble de la communauté de
défense se mobiliser c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis présent sur le
terrain à la rencontre de nos militaires
comme je le ferai demain tout le monde
par exemple pour la marine nationale
mais aussi la parole est à notre
collègue madame nicole bricq pour le
groupe socialiste président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre le 26
janvier dernier la commission sauvé a
remis un rapport au président de la
république pour une nouvelle déontologie
de la vie publique
aussitôt connu ce rapport a été vivement
critiquée par la majorité et vous-même
premier ministre n'avait pas été le
moins sévère car vous avez choisi une
proposition qui consiste à interdire un
manque de gouvernement d'être
responsable d'un parti politique
et vous avez déclaré je vous cite c'est
juste le contraire de la démocratie
il est vrai que cette proposition fait
explicitement référence au cas de
l'ancien ministre du budget qui cumulait
sa fonction avec celle de trésorier de
l'ump
et je rappelle que c'est quand même le
cas qui avait motivé la demande du
président de la république à la
commission sauvé mais la mise en cause
récente d'une autre ministre de la
république semble précipité les choses
c'est ainsi que le 9 février au conseil
des ministres
vous avez présenté les premières
orientations de ce qui pourrait être un
texte de loi est mentionné une mesure
sur les 29 que compte le rapport celles
qui visent la déclaration d'intérêt
applicable aux membres du gouvernent
man et aux conseillers des cabinets
ministériels vous avez du reste indiqué
monsieur le premier ministre
quel pourrait être mise en oeuvre sans
attendre le projet de loi il ya en effet
urgence aux rythmes précipité des
départs de cabinets ministériels souvent
vers le privé
al'approche de l'élection présidentielle
mais nous craignons qu'il ne s'agisse
que d'un contre-feu à une actualité
pressante et la méthode qui consiste à
sélectionner une mesure pour
décrédibiliser les autres est une
vieille ficelle politicienne l' annonce
faite le 9 février doit se traduire vite
et pleinement dans un texte sans qu'a
priori on écarte les pistes qui gêne
s'il s'agit d'un texte de loi
sa mise en débat au parlement sera
rapidement un gage de transparence
démocratique la république en a grand
besoin
le gouvernement est il prêt à cet
exercice et dans quel délai merci la
parole est un monsieur françois baroin
ministre du budget des comptes publics
de la fonction publique et de la réforme
de l'état
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur madame bric c'est le prix dont
la république qui a sollicité le
vice-président du conseil d'état pour
rédiger un rapport sur la définition des
frontières concernant les conflits
d'intérêts c'est le gouvernement et le
premier ministre lui même il y a
quelques jours vous l'avez rappelé qu'
au conseil des ministres a annoncé son
intention de déposer dans les toutes les
prochaines semaines un texte sur la
délimitation qui permettra à la
représentation nationale
s'agissant des conflits d'intérêts de
bien faire la part des choses dans
l'exercice des responsabilités pas
seulement ministériel évidemment des
membres du cabinet vous l'avez dit de
toute la haute fonction publique des
magistrats il n'est pas douteux que la
représentation nationale s'intéressera à
son propre cas il n'est pas douteux que
le groupe à l'assemblée nationale animés
par la haine grosskost et monsieur
balligand formulerons des propositions
concernant les députés il n'est pas
douteux que le travail de monsieur y est
accompagnée par des membres de
l'opposition formulera son tour des
propositions de telle sorte que nous
aurons ensemble me semble-t-il la
possibilité de définir un consensus
autour
ce qui va vers le sens d'une plus grande
transparence et donc de ce qui va dans
la bonne direction
tirant les leçons des besoins de la
société et tirant les leçons également
des besoins d'absence définitif de
porosité entre le milieu privé le milieu
public vous permettez juste une
observation sur l'un des points que vous
avez souligné dans votre question qui
porte sur la remarque concernant la
situation d'un membre du gouvernement
chef de parti j'aurais l'étendre à celle
d'un membre de gouvernements
responsables d'exécutifs il est aussi la
responsabilité des politiques élus au
suffrage universel qui incarne la nation
de dire aussi ce que nous souhaitons
comme élément démocratique
il n'appartient pas au vice président du
conseil d'état de dire qu'il y à
conflits d'intérêts privés lorsque
quelqu'un est responsable d'un exécutif
local et responsable d'une mission
publique nationale
nous sommes dans le public public donc
oui nous ferons des choix comme disait
gide choisir c'est renoncer
nous ne renoncerons pas à aller vers une
plus grande transparence
nous ne renoncerons pas à déposer un
texte dont nous souhaitons qu'il soit le
plus consensuel possible mais nous ne
renoncerons pas avoir une démocratie
vivante où tout le monde pourra
participer aux affaires de notre pays
merci la parole est maintenant un autre
collègue serge dassault pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
unifia collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame me charger l'apprentissage de la
formation professionnelle madame nadine
morano
madame je suis heureux de constater que
vous allez développer l'alternance
massivement avec l'apprentissage
c'est pourquoi je voudrais avoir savoir
comment vous allez procéder sur le plan
budgétaire
car l'alternance et et si d'une part des
centres de formation des cfa dont le
nombre est insuffisant surtout dans le
bâtiment et d'autre part des entreprises
qui veulent bien accepter les apprentis
aujourd'hui malheureusement très peu
d'entreprises accepte de prendre des
apprentis pour diverses raisons
on parle aussi d'un accompagnement
intensif des chômeurs ce qui est bien
mais par qui et comment car effective le
pôle emploi des missions locales sont
déjà insuffisants il faut être con cela
augmenter les budgets de jeunes et
organismes à la fois pour leur personnel
et les formations proposées
je souhaite que les 500 millions
annoncés par monsieur le président la
république encore concernant les
contrats aidés concerne le moins de
contrats aidés non-marchands possible
car ils sont d'une efficacité très
relative et que c'est à 100 millions une
partie sera affectée au cfa aux
entreprises pendant les apprentis au
pôle emploi aux maisons de l'emploi avec
les formations associées en tant que
rapporteur spécial du budget de l'emploi
vous comprendrez que ces questions me
préoccupe à thuir mans et je voulais
savoir combien l'ensemble de ses moyens
nécessaires va coûter à mon budget il ya
des questions pour vous rappeler le
meilleur moyen de réduire le chômage /
est de flexibilité les emplois
intérimaires et des contrats de mission
et cela ne coûterait rien à l'état
qu'en pensez vous et dernier remarque ne
pensez vous pas que si le service
militaire n'avait pas été supprimés tous
ces problèmes sur est moins critique
merci bien
madame nadine morano ministre chargée de
l'apprentissage et de la formation
professionnelle vous répond merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur serge dassault vous avez raison
de dire qu'il faut dans notre pays
développés les formations par alternance
et l'apprentissage
il suffit de regarder de l'autre côté de
la frontière en allemagne pour voir le
taux de chômage des jeunes faible 10%
pour voir le taux de chômage des
entreprises luttent au pardon des
entreprises qui utilisent des apprentis
de plus de 60 % alors qu'en france les
entreprises utilisent seulement les
apprentis de l'ordre de 33%
le décalage est énorme évidemment et en
allemagne
il y a cette mentalité qui dure depuis
des décennies de la formation duale que
nous n'avons pas en france
parce que nous nous sommes trompés
stratégie pendant des années la majorité
à l'époque de gauche nous tenait un
discours 80 % d'une classe d'âge au bac
ce qui est une erreur gigantesque
puisqu'il nous faut 100 % de jeunes
formés 100 % de jeunes formés dans
toutes les filières vous avez raison de
dire aussi que nous avons 250 mille
emplois qui sont régulièrement non
pourvus parce que nous ne trouvons pas
de personnel formé pour répondre à ces
emplois alors nous disposons monsieur le
sénateur de plusieurs leviers pour agir
le premier levier c'est d'abord les 500
millions d'euros du grand emprunt pour
investir massivement dans des centres de
formations adaptées à travers des ses
phares moderniser à travers des ces
femmes dans lesquelles nous
mutualiseront les moyens et aussi parce
que c'est important si nous voulons des
jeunes apprentis formés
il faut pouvoir aussi les héberger sur
notre territoire nous allons créer
quinze mille places supplémentaires
d'hébergement pour les apprentis c'est
un premier levier
nous avons avec xavier bertrand nous
allons négocier les prochains contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens avec les
régions et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs l'emploi des jeunes c'est un
objectif national partagé l'état chaque
année va investir 350 millions d'euros
en moyenne et bien face à noron engagées
par l'état
nous souhaitons que les régions engage
aussi l 1 euro fasse un euro engagée par
l'état que chacun prenne sa part de
responsabilités que chacun s'engage pour
l'emploi c'est une nécessité absolue
attendu par tous nos concitoyens
maintenant la parole et à monsieur rené
pierre signé pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question s'adresse à
monsieur ne misait la santé monsieur
xavier bertrand
monsieur le ministre les militants du
planning familial s'inquiète de la
menace qui pèse sur l'accès des femmes à
l'avortement dans de bonnes conditions
elle apparaît comme une remise en cause
non avouée d'un droit acquis de haute
lutte
aujourd'hui les délais augmente de façon
considérable les femmes doivent attendre
plus de trois semaines
pour accéder à ces services renvoyer
d'hôpital en hôpital en raison des
restructurations liées à la loi bachelot
hspt qui a réduit le nombre de services
mais aussi le nombre de médecins
pratiquant cet acte en othe le
désengagement du privé a fait passer la
part du secteur public de 64 à 70 %
concentrant ainsi les actes et
allongeant le temps d'attentes mise
ainsi hors délai elles sont contraintes
d'aller avorter à l'étranger pour celles
qui le peuvent
la revendication porte sur l'application
totale de la loi 2001 la loi aubry qui
dépénalise les ivg et repousse des les
élèves des rigal d'un vêtement de 10 à
12 semaines autorise en outre les
mineurs à se faire avorter sans
autorisation parentale
la protestation qui prend aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'ampleur est liée à une
régression indiscutable d'abord par la
restructuration des hôpitaux
ensuite par le peu de mobilisation du
personnel médical pour un acte souvent
mal acceptée mal perçu et peut
considérer financièrement orly vg est un
acte médical
un acte médical à part entière même si
de nombreux médecins refusent de
l'appliquer après cette semaine pour
exemple pour des raisons d'éthique ou
parce que de médicamenteuse où elle est
mal encadré
douloureuse elle devient après sept
semaines plus chirurgicale il se
distancie ainsi de leur responsabilité
mais in fine la loi enl ivg est un acte
gynécologique ordinaire d'autre part la
faiblesse du forfait payé par la
sécurité sociale
ra son accès difficile à certaines
femmes le forfait hospitalier devait
être augmentée 50% selon l'engagement de
madame bachelot
on souhaite que cette promesse a été
tenue je n'en suis pas sûr
ma question est donc simple et repose
sur trois points essentiels monsieur le
ministre
premièrement accueilli élargi y compris
aux mineurs sans autorisation parentale
dans les servicemen plus nombreux
deuxièmement acceptation de 12 semaines
comme des les interventions
troisièmement forfait hospitalier
versées par la sécurité sociale
réellement augmenter comme promis à une
question aussi simple on est en droit
d'obtenir une réponse claire et précise
merci monsieur xavier bertrand ministre
du travail de l'emploi et de la santé
vous réponds présent mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez oublié une chose les
vg médicamenteuse ivg médicamenteuses
vous n'avez pas assisté sur ce point
pour dire qu'aujourd'hui pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui si vous avez
effectivement un recul du nombre
d'interventions chirurgicales
c'est aussi parce qu'ils y arriver j'ai
médicamenteuse qui a trouvé toute sa
place toute sa place tendez ne revenons
pas je veux je pense qu'il est important
sur ce sujet de bien montrer les choses
est de montrer que l'évolution vous avez
évoqué net expliqué dans vos propos que
de façon partielle disons les choses
très clairement
vous dites que vous dites que c'est
depuis je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
arguments gêne avant même qu'ils ne
soient développées je ne comprends pas
ce que je voulais vous dire vous avez
parlé de restructuration liés à la loi
bachelot vous savez pertinemment que ce
n'est pas la raison et vous savez aussi
pertinemment parce que vous avez l'air
d'avoir développé le sujet de façon
construite que 5 % des établissements
pratiquent 23 % des ivg dans notre pays
5 % 23 % et que là où il y a eu des
fermetures de services
c'est pour des raisons liées à la
sécurité des patients
parce que le nombre d'actes et vous le
savez pertinemment était inférieure à un
seuil et que je suis désolé de le dire
moi en pratique moyenne praticiens plus
les patients savent que les conditions
de sécurité ne sont pas les mêmes tout
simplement parce que vous savez aussi
pertinemment que le choix de la
proximité et même un choix qui fait
réaliser des économies à la sécurité
sociale
ce n'est donc pas un objectif de
rentabilité quand vous avez la fermeture
d'un service parce qu'il n'y a plus
assez de praticiens et qu'on est obligé
de laisser au père à 50 ou 80 km vous
êtes obligés de payer les transports
sanitaires la preuve que c'est pas une
question d'économie
c'est tout simplement la sécurité des
actes donc je tiens à le dire comme
roselyne bachelot l'avait précisé
je suis très attentif comme nora berra à
ce que ce droit puissent être garanties
sur l'ensemble du territoire
sur la question des forfaits deux choses
c'est que la tarification à l'activité
doit bien évidemment prendre en compte
la juste rémunération de ces taxes est
que nous devons aussi et c'est ce que
j'aurai à coeur de faire dans la
campagne tarifaire avoir des migac des
missions d'intérêt général qui soit bel
et bien garantie parce que je pense que
l'hôpital ne peut marcher que sur deux
jambes la tarification à l'activité les
migac ça n'a pas toujours été le cas par
le passé
je veillerai à ce que ce soit assuré
par ailleurs sur toutes les questions
que vous avez évoquées nous serons
particulièrement vigilants que ce droit
parce qu'il s'agit bien d'un droits
soient garantis pour tout je dis bien
tout sur le territoire français ça ne
sert à rien sur tous ces sujets de
chercher à faire croire qu'il y ait un
recul du droit qu'il y aurait des
restructurations par souci d'économie
quand il y en a c'est pour des raisons
de sécurité c'est notre seule ligne
directrice
bien maintenant nous allons entendre
notre collègue philippe adnot pour leurs
réunions administratives des sénateurs
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
monsieur nouvelles et par heure je vous
remercie monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre richerdt chargé des
collectivités locales monsieur le
ministre
pourriez vous nous éclairer sur la
méthode employée pour attribuer les
dotations de l'état concernant la
prestation de compensation du handicap
le rsa le revenu de solidarité active et
l'apa l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie
l'écart entre les dotations de l'état
concernant les trois prestations
obligatoires et la dépense réels
supportés par les départements ne cesse
de se creuser et constitue une équation
impossible dans la tente d'une réforme
qui devra faire une plus grande place à
la solidarité nationale
vous avez prévu de répartir une première
dotation de 75 millions d'euros
attribuée à 30 départements dont j'ai
ici la liste
intrigué par l'absence où la présence de
certains départements j'ai procédé à une
analyse comparative avec un document qui
vient d'être publiée par dexia à partir
des comptes administratifs de 2009 tout
le monde peut se le procurer
le voici ma surprise a été grande de
constater qu'il y avait des restes à
charge par habitant extrêmement
différent selon la prestation fournie
ainsi il y a des départements pour le
rsa qui ont touché plus qu'il n'avait de
dépenses - 15 euros à plus 50 euros
qu'il y en avait d'autres qui avaient un
sur deux des plus de 75 ans qui relevait
de l'apa pendant que la moyenne se situe
plutôt à un sur quatre ou un sur cinq
il doit y avoir des microclimats qui s'y
prêtent
et donc ma question monsieur le ministre
est la suivante si les restes à charge
par département sont à ce point
différent c'est que la règle
d'attribution ne doit pas être la même
et donc je suis je vous le demande la
solidarité suppose la transparence
pourriez-vous d'une part nous
communiquer les éléments de calcul qui
ont servi de base à l'attribution des 75
millions d'euros et d'autre part nous
éclairer sur la méthode employée pour
attribuer les trois dotations de l'état
concernant les prestations sociales
obligatoires
je vous en remercie par avance merci
monsieur philippe richert ministre
chargé des collectivités territoriales
va vous répondre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs cher sénateur
philippe adnot
merci de la question ça va me permettre
de répondre de façon très précise
l'évolution des relations entre l'état
le gouvernement et les départements qui
sont nous le savons dans une situation
de défaite ciseaux notamment du fait de
l'évolution des dépenses sociales
cette relation a beaucoup changé ces
derniers temps tout d'abord parce que il
ya quatre mécanismes qui viennent d'être
mises en place le premier de ces
mécanismes vous en parliez c'est
l'institution d'un montant de 75
millions d'euros pour les départements
les plus fragiles vous demander quels
sont les critères qui ont été mis en
place pour la répartition de ces 75
millions c'est très simple ce sont les
critères qui se trouve explicitement
dans la loi à savoir le revenu par
habitant à savoir le potentiel financier
et à savoir troisièmement la proportion
de personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans
dans le département
donc c'est très spécifique et c'est
comme ça qu'on a été amené à faire la
liste étant département malheureusement
l'obligé pas mais c'est bien de façon
tout à fait claires et transparentes
deuxième chose
la mise en place d'une péréquation au
niveau des mt au vous savez puisque vous
y avez participé ici au niveau du sénat
qui est tout simplement de de faire en
sorte que l'une des contributions pour
permettre la prise en charge de la part
sociale des départements soit mieux
répartie
nous savons que les départements au
souffert avec la crise du fait de la
diminution des droits de mutation les dm
théo mais en même temps certains
départements ont vu cdmt aux sons stocks
très importants repartir très vite nous
avons donc fait une péréquation qui nous
permettra de répartir là aussi des
montants relativement substantielles qui
puisqu'il devrait se situer entre 350 et
400 millions d'euros
nous aurons les réponses d'ici la fin du
mois de février avec les répartitions
qui là encore se font en fonction des
critères que nous avons arrêtés ensemble
au niveau du débat au parlement
la troisième chose c'est le vrai débat
c'est certains départements risquent
d'être dans une situation qui malgré ses
amendements restent délicates à ce
moment là un troisième fonds de 75
millions d'euros est mis en place et qui
permettra ponctuellement d'aider les
départements dans les situations les
plus délicates
dernière chose enfin c'est la plus
importante c'est que le débat sur la
dépendance a été lancée vous le savez
roselyne bachelot a mis en place les
quatre groupes de travail
au plan national il fonctionne le
président de la république était présent
au niveau du conseil économique social
et environnemental pour permettre le
lancement de de ce grand débat qui nous
concerne tous il concerne bien sûr pas
que les départements il concerne
l'avenir de la façon dont nous voyons la
relation entre les différentes
générations qui constitue notre socle
social dans notre pays est bien dans le
cadre de ce travail qui avait ait refait
les départements évidemment sont très
étroitement associés et je vous propose
de regarder à cette occasion comment
notamment l'apa peut être compensée et
compenser et pourra être compensé demain
de façon à ce que là aussi ce soit
totalement transparent je vous remercie
de m'avoir donné l'occasion de préciser
l'ensemble de ces nouveaux dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place par le
gouvernement au niveau des relations
avec les départements
merci messieurs ministre donc nous avons
fini avec les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
le premier président de la cour des
comptes va faire son entrée dans 5
minutes à peu près 5 6 minutes
voilà vous venez d'assister aux
questions d'actualité en ce jeudi
évidemment au sénat on va refaire la
séance dans quelques secondes
bienvenue sur public sénat pour on
refait la séance avec nous jean-pierre
belge label bonjour bonjour président du
groupe socialiste
ici au sénat ce matin une audition de la
commission des affaires étrangères le
parti socialiste et des alliances de
gauche vous avez décidé de boycotter
cette audition de michèle alliot marie
donc de ne pas y aller ne pas y aller
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer cette décision
écoutez il ya une petite nuance parce
que c'était pas vraiment mot d'ordre
c'était une attaque collective parce
qu'il ya un moment où on peut dire assez
ça suffit on a voulu manifester notre
exaspération devant une situation qui à
notre sens est grandement pénalisant
pour notre pays pour la france la parole
de la france dans le monde aujourd'hui
est vu au travers de cette affaire et
nous pensons que vraiment c'est
exaspérant de
voir que les responsables au plus haut
niveau ne sont pas capables de prendre
leurs responsabilités je crois qu'il y
est il est un moment c'est d'ailleurs la
tradition républicaine ou dans ce pays
où ceux qui nous gouvernent doivent
tirer les conséquences d'une situation
est aujourd'hui il est bien temps de
sortir de cette affaire de ce problème
par le haut mais pour un parti qui se
dit républicain ne pas aller lors d'une
réunion d'une audition de la ministre
des affaires étrangères
est ce que vous pensez sincèrement
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est normal
écoutez nous allons passer l'après midi
d'hier avec madame alliot marie sur de
débat un débat sur l'union pour la
méditerranée est un autre débat sur
l'amérique latine et caraïbes dont nous
avons essayé de participer et de
débattre et d'ailleurs nous avons noté
certains signes d'énervement mais il ya
un moment où on peut pousser un coup de
gueule lorsque on se trouve dans une
telle situation tout paraît bloquée et
aucun responsable n'accepte de prendre
ses responsabilités il est du devoir
d'un groupe d'opposition d'un groupe
parlementaire de hausser le ton et d'une
certaine manière manière d'exprimer
cette exaspération qui ressenti je vous
le dis par beaucoup de français en ont
assez d'entendre ces histoires qui
semaine après semaine et ne font
qu'aggraver et faire en sorte et faire
en définitive que l'image de notre pays
dans le monde ne gagnez pas bien au
contraire
aussi le ton s'est demandé la démission
de michèle alliot marie écoutez nous
greffer par jean marc ayrault le
président une vitre sans nous ne devons
pas tomber dans une espèce d'opposition
qui pourrait apparaître comme
politicienne entre notre groupes
politiques d'opposition les socialistes
et les goûts et les gouvernements nous
ne faisons pas d'obsession sur la
personne de madame alliot marie d'un
moment il faut trouver des solutions une
situation donc c'est tout à elle de
tirer les conséquences de du mouvement
dans lequel on trouve en et au président
de la république d'arbitré si elle ne
sait pas elle même prendre ses
responsabilités pour le reste nous nous
voulons vraiment que
le la voix de la france dans le monde
puisse retrouver le niveau qui sera à la
hauteur des enjeux ou salés je vous
propose c'était donc un coup de gueule
de la part du papier sécurisé assure ici
au sénat par mail vous restez avec nous
quelques petites minutes avec plaisir
merci jean arthuis nous a rejoint
bonjour bonjour sénateur de la mayenne
président de la commission des finances
vous avez une question très importante
scène de la désertification des médecins
en france
est ce que c'est un vrai réel problème
aujourd'hui on a plus de médecins en
france
oui c'est vrai un certain nombre de
territoires voit les médecins partir en
retraite sans remplaçant parce que les
jeunes médecins veulent exercer dans
d'autres conditions
pour tenter d'enrayer ce phénomène et
répondre à l attente de ces territoires
des populations qui vivent la loi
hôpital patients santé territoires à
imaginer que l'on puisse rémunéré
certains étudiants
à condition qu'ils choisissent d'exercer
lorsqu'ils seront diplômés dans un de
ces territoires
j'observe que sur le terrain ça ne
démarre pas pourquoi parce que plane le
doute de l'affectation tel jeunes qui
seraient désireux de s'installer dans un
département rural où il ya manifestement
un besoin de médecins jeunes on ne peux
pas l'assurer qu'il exercera dans ce
département lui dit va peut-être que
vous irez à l'autre bout de la france ce
qui peut être merveilleux mais ça ne
répond pas là jean louis lejeune ne
s'engage pas et ça ne démarre pas et
notamment dans la région des pays de la
loire et nous avons une espèce de
blocage et dont j'ai voulu saisir
l'occasion de ces questions d'actualité
pour rendre le ministre chargé de la
santé attentif à la nécessité de faire
preuve de pragmatisme de résolution et
de dire d'emblée aux jeunes où ils vont
pouvoir exercer
alors concrètement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer sur une
proposition de loi examinée ce soir dans
l'hémicycle celle de jean pierre
fourcade
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qu'il va se passer il y avait une sorte
de bonus malus pour les médecins ont
donné un petit peu plus une aide coup de
pouce supplémentaire en terme d'argent
pour les médecins qui étaient prêts à
aller en région
alors est ce que vous voulez des
supprimés ça c'est un autre phénomène
je pense qu'il faut surtout joué sur
l'attractivité d'un territoire
je doute que l'on puisse forcer des
médecins s'installer quelque part car
bien souvent il y à la situation du
conjoint
et si un médecin a épousé une jeune
femme aussi une une jeune femme médecin
a pour conjoint un homme qui lui
exerce dans une grande agglomération
c'est bien difficile de les obliger à
aller sur un territoire donc je crois ce
qu'il faut c'est préparer l'organisation
de l'exercice de la médecine
imaginez des maisons de santé des pôles
médicaux qu'ils soient des oserais-je
dire des micros clinique qui assureront
la permanence des soins et au sein
desquelles sept huit neuf dix médecins
avec d'autres acteurs de santé des
kinésithérapeutes des infirmiers
pourront exercer
il ya même des actes médicaux qui
aujourd'hui sont sous la responsabilité
des médecins et qui pourrait
parfaitement être pris en charge par des
infirmiers ou des infirmières ayant de
l'expérience ayant de vraies compétences
et qu'il ferait équipe avec ses médecins
jean arthuis je vois que jean pierre bel
veut absolument vous répondre sur cette
question vous qui êtes de l'ariège parle
pas de lui répondre je veux appuyer le
l'initiative de jean arthuis d'avoir
posé cette question parce que c'est une
vrai souci un vrai problème et il a bien
sûr parlé des pays de la loire mais je
veux dire que c'est dans la plupart des
régions et bien sûr vous êtes touchés
dans la mienne en ariège en particulier
mon département nous constatons les
phénomènes que jean arthuis décrit et
quant aux solutions on est prêt à en
discuter parce qu'un effet il faut
trouver des solutions
jean arthuis j'ai une petite question
sur l'impôt sur la fortune vous savez
que ça fait toute l'actualité cette
semaine le président de la république a
déclaré ce matin qu'il préférait une
grosse noix avec des petites
conséquences plutôt qu'une petite loi
avec des petites conséquence également
qu'est ce que vous entendez le président
de la république sur cette question est
ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura une
grande loi sur la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune et du bouclier fiscal
écoutez moi ma position est très claire
le bouclier fiscal ne s'applique pas au
revenu de référence mais au revenu
fiscal c'est à dire après qu'on ai
déduit de son revenu des abattements des
réductions des réductions des
défiscalisations loi girardin ou
d'autres qui sont à la limite du
scandale par rapport à l'idée que je me
fais de la justice fiscale et par
conséquent ce bouclier est emblématique
d'une forme d'injustice il faut abroger
le bouclier fiscal la suge crois que
nous sommes d'accord mais comme le
bouclier fiscal
vous pourrez a été imaginé pour répondre
un autre très mauvais impôt que seule la
france pratique lisf il faut avoir le
courage d'être suffisamment pédagogue
pour expliquer le bien fondé de
l'abrogation tout à la fois du bouclier
et de l'isf
et comme il manque à peu près deux
milliards 3 milliards pour équilibrer
les comptes publics
eh bien il faut accepter que l'on
institue une tranche supplémentaire
d'impôt progressif sur le revenu à 45%
pour les revenus les plus élevés que
l'on revoit également l'assiette qu'on a
beaucoup rétréci et les taux
d'imposition des plus values mobilières
et immobilières
hélas le compte y sera merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui je crois que vous allez
rejoindre la séance et que vous êtes un
petit peu pressé cour des comptes pour
la cour des comptes absolument on va
vous laisser rejoindre las
on va continuer avec jean pierre bel
justement sur l' isf est ce que vous
voulez répondre à jean arthuis qui est
en jeu et pas lui répondre parce que
c'est un débat qui va être assez violent
partir ainsi lors d'un point de vue du
groupe sur le bouclier fiscal
bien entendu nous l'avons suffisamment
dénoncé pour ne pas aller dans le sens
de ceux qui veulent le supprimer tout
simplement pour des raisons de justice
sociale sur l'impôt sur la fortune
là il ya un débat qui est beaucoup plus
entre nous peut-être qu'il va nous
opposer
parce que nous n'avons certainement pas
la même vision nous sommes pas opposés
forcément à une réforme de l'impôt sur
la fortune
mais vous savez il faut déjà retrouvé ce
que le l'impôt sur la fortune nous amène
en ressources
avant même de songer à le supprimer jean
permet une petite question sur les
sénatoriales ça se prépare septembre
c'est pour bientôt
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'au
parti socialiste et notamment martine
aubry
vous êtes suffisamment aidé on sent
quelques sénateurs ici qui nous disent
ici et là par exemple sur la
constitution des listes et bah c'est pas
tout à fait ça écoutez c'est une c'est
une pratique normale à la veille d'un de
rendez vous comme celui là on est vous
important l'élection sénatoriale
nous sommes à droite à gauche au centre
à préparer nos listes et à désigner le
candidat alors il ya toujours des
difficultés qui intervient de ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que nous sentons
que 2011 sera une année clé car
7 à mon sens la seule possibilité pour
le sénat d'être légitimé être légitimé
pour le sénat c'est lui faire connaître
l'alternance toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour que l'alternance puisse
venir au sénat puisque la gauche est
majoritaire dans les communes dans les
départements dans les régions donc
forcément si au lendemain des élections
sénatoriales
nous constations que une nouvelle fois
c'est la droite qui reste est
majoritaire dans cette maison il y
aurait peut-être un petit problème sur
lequel les démocrates notamment ceux qui
sont attachés à la démocratie
parlementaire courir cet orge et
historique ici au sénat que la gauche
prenne le pouvoir et soit le réel poids
d'opposition ici en france mais on sent
pas à solférino un point majeur pour
cette élection vous trompez vous trempez
pour l'instant nous avons les élections
cantonales qui sont devant nous et pour
les disques raid pour les gatineau les
en tout cas pour l'instant
je crois que ce ceux qui ceux qui sont
discrets et plutôt à l'échelle du
gouvernement entend peu parler des
élections cantonales
elles sont très importantes et croyez
moi ce sera un marqueur qui doha qui
donnera beaucoup d'indications sur les
élections qui vont suivre
c'est à dire les élections sénatoriales
merci beaucoup jean pierre bel un
évidement vous l'avez rappelé il y aura
bientôt les élections cantonales que
vous pourrez suivre évidemment sur
public sénat jean pierre fourcade nous a
rejoint
bonjour peut-être un thème très
important lors de ces élections
cantonales c'est la proposition de loi
que vous allez donc vous allez débattre
en fin de journée ici
au sénat sur la désertification médicale
c'est pas exactement le thème le thème
c'est que le gouvernement m'a chargé de
dévaluer sur le terrain la loi hôpitaux
hôpital patients sécurité santé
territoires et au fur et à mesure des
auditions qu'elle je projette et des
visites que je fais sur place je vois
que dans la loi il ya un certain nombre
de points qui sont à l'heure actuelle
des aspérités ou des blocages et mon
texte n'est pas fait pour lutter contre
la désertification car il faudrait des
textes beaucoup plus important mon texte
et pour permettre que la mise en place
de la nouvelle gouvernance des hôpitaux
de la nouvelle
méthodes de travail des agences
régionales de santé souvent dans des
conditions correctes et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai avec l'appui des deux
cabinets celui de madame bachelot et
celui de monsieur bertrand fait une
proposition de quelques articles qui
consiste à gommer quelques aspérités à
améliorer la déconcentration vers les
ars a essayé de mieux discuter avec
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
qu'ils soient médecins ou auxiliaires de
santé et surtout à mettre en place une
nouvelle est une nouvelle structure qui
est la société interprofessionnelle de
soins ambulatoires qui doit permettre
sur le terrain de réunir des médecins
des auxiliaires de santé des dentistes
des pharmaciens est de leur donner un
statut que nous avons longuement discuté
avec les ministères intéressés et avec
la chancellerie
françois patriat nous a rejoint bonjour
françois patriat je termine juste avec
jean perfectible mais je voulais quand
même vous présentez vous êtes venu sur
notre plateau je vous en remercie jean
pierre fourcade sur ce point sur ce que
vous allez de débattre sur cette
proposition de loi est ce que c'est un
retour en arrière du touriste au
contraire certains dits vais peut-être
la gauche de dirac c'est une mesure
électoraliste pas du tout ce n'est pas
une mesure électoraliste c'est
simplement comme je suis chargé pour la
première fois la loi prévue d'un seul
article 35 qui aurait une évaluation sur
le terrain avec un rapport au parlement
je suis lent chargé de faire ce rapport
je vais donc un peu partout en france et
enfin en métropole et dans les
départements d'outre-mer
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de blocages blocage avec des syndicats
médicaux de médecins libéraux blocage
avec certaines structures hospitalières
blocage avec les psychiatres blocage
avec tel ou tel est par conséquent
j'essaie par des mesures qui ne
remettent absolument pas en cause
l'objectif central de la loi où son
équilibre d'essayer de faciliter la mise
en place par exemple de la coopération
interhospitalière ou d
des mesures qui peuvent intéresser le
secteur médico social c'est la première
fois que les agences régionales de santé
vont s'occuper sérieusement de tous les
établissements médico-sociaux et il ya
là un secteur très important et on leur
applique dans la loi des formalités des
procédures peu trop lourde que j'ai
c'est d'alléger
selon vous est ce qu'il faudrait faire
appel à des médecins étrangers peut-être
pour justement ces déserts médicaux
n'ont ensuite pas une paille à déjeuner
nous avons en matière de nombre de
médecins suffisamment de médecins en
france aujourd'hui mais d'une part il ya
beaucoup de spécialistes et pas
suffisamment de médecins de médecine
générale et et d'autre part il ya des
secteurs dans laquelle il ya une
surmédicalisation et des secteurs avec
une démographie très faible mais je le
crois pas qu'on puisse favoriser trouver
d incitation suffisante pour favoriser l
installation individuelle
je crois maintenant au centre de soins
aux maisons médicales à ces sociétés
interprofessionnelles associant médecins
infirmières kinés etc
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera à améliorer la
territorialisation et la qualité des
soins pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
la question jean pierre fourcade est ce
que vous pensez être suivi sur votre
proposition de loi écoute un jeu
consensus je pense selon eux il ya
beaucoup d'amendements mais je pense que
je serai suivi parce que les choses se
mettent en place il ya eu pendant la
discussion du texte de grandes
oppositions aussi bien de certains
grands maîtres du tissu hospitalier que
de médecins libéraux
je prends tous est en train de se passer
est que les problèmes de sécurité déçoit
les problèmes de territorialisation les
problèmes de coopération entre le public
et le privé sont en train de se mettre
en place
je veux les inciter à accélérer un petit
peu en supprimant quelques aspérités de
la loi merci jean pierre fourcade
remercie d'être venu sur notre plateau
je me retourne donc vers un françois
patriat
bonjour des nouveaux bons jours
dominique strauss kahn arrive à paris
bientôt ce week-end pour la préparation
du g20
est ce que pour vous c'est encore une
fois un signe
est-ce qu'il serait temps comme le
disent certains à gauche il se déclare
en tout cas qu'il parle de mini
strauss-kahn vient régulièrement en
france dominique strauss kahn se tient
régulièrement informé de la situation
économique sociale et politique de la
france
il vient d'abord parce que son pays et
qu'il est profondément français je le
rappelle nonobstant quelques voix que
j'ai entendu ce week-end et puis que
dans le même temps je crois dans son
rôle aujourd'hui c'est bien ils veillent
avec un soin particulier à ce qu'est
l'europe est un secret ils remettent
qu'il peut apporter au pays français
donc je crois que dominique strauss-kahn
vient pour parler de sa fonction de son
rôle de sa vision est il besoin de
demander le temps de se présenter
maintenant nombre je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui quelle stakhanovisme pousse
certains d'entre ses amis et surtout des
adversaires à se prononcer aujourd'hui
ce que je vois surtout c'est que la
gauche la montée en puissance d'amour
l'exemple de jean marc ayrault le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée qui lui dit peut-être qu'il
serait temps qu'ils se déclarent tout
simplement pour arrêter ce petit jeu je
ne pense pas qu'il soit bon que les élus
de gauche aussi prestigieux soit-il et
jean marc ayrault est mon ami de mettre
lui-même la pression sur un processus
dont on connaît aujourd'hui les dates le
déroulement
alors que d'autres disent qu'ils se
prononceront plus tard j'ai vu certains
candidats aux primaires dia qui se
présenteront un soit après les
cantonales soit homogène
laissons à dominique strauss kahn jr et
son temps il faut donner du sens au
temps et pas seulement du temps au temps
et les sondages qui sont un petit peu en
baisse est ce que ça vous inquiète moi
je ne lis pas comme tel et quand on part
de très haut
une pub et descendre bien entendu je
crois surtout c'est que il ya des blocs
qui se perpétue qui montrent ce que
sondage après sondage
la classe la notoriété et l'ont vite
demi strauss kahn se maintient à très
haut niveau
elle peut fluctuer au cours de telle ou
telle semaine
l'art est très haute et le reste avec un
écart sans précédent avec ses
challengers potentiels
il est prévu une rencontre avec
dominique strauss kahn
pas du tout pour ce week-end pas du tout
non non très bien merci beaucoup merci
entre iya sénateur de côte-d'or josset
devrons nous viennent de nous rejoindre
bonjour vous êtes le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères ici
au sénat ce matin michèle alliot marie a
été auditionné vous étiez présent lors
de cette audition
qu'est-ce qu'on peut ressortir de cette
audition par rapport déjà d'une part à
la crise france mexique
et je vous interrogera presse sur la
crise qui touche le monde arabe bien sûr
là la crise france mexique
elle a expliqué les conditions dans
lesquelles se déroulait la sphère
florence k 16 les raisons qui avaient
amené le gouvernement français à réagir
comme il l'a fait en faisant état du
fait que des promesses qui avaient été
faites au président de la république
notamment par le président calderon
n'avaient pas été tenues aussi fait
remarquer que les conditions dans
lesquelles s'était déroulé le procès et
puisque le contestable constituait d'une
certaine manière une violation des
droits de l'homme et qu'elle souhaitait
évidemment nous avions souhaité
le transfèrement de florence k 16 dans
une hutte détention en france et indiqué
que le gouvernement mexicain s'y
opposaient nous avons eu un échange de
vues sur ce sujet notamment notre
collègue banastère quiétude autorités
comme chacun sait a fait remarquer que
la justice mexicaine était souveraine
dans son pays et que il était
souhaitable que au moins un minimum nous
reconnaissions le droit pour les juges
mexicains de se prononcer comme ils le
font même s'il ne sommes pas d'accord il
faut respecter la souveraineté du
mexique alors ce que nous souhaitons
c'est ce que nous avons souhaité c'est
qu'on essaye de trouver des solutions
pour régler ce problème très douloureux
faire en sorte qu'elles soient détenues
dans des conditions convenables et aussi
qu' on puisse discuter un jour de son
transfert monroe est ce que l'attitude
des députés qui sont allés sur le
fronton de l'assemblée nationale faire
une photo avec les parents de florence
cassez
quelle est votre réaction quand vous
voyez cette photo est cette décision qui
a été prise par les députés les élus est
ce que vous seriez capable de faire la
même chose en ville c'est leur manière
de voir
moi je suis partisan d'autre solution je
pense que ce qu'il faut c'est que l'on
maintienne le contact avec les mecs ical
qu'on ne les agréent spa et quand
respecteur souveraineté tout en étant
capable de leur dire que nous souhaitons
une solution humaine à ce cas qui est
très douloureuse est-ce qu pour florence
cassez s'est pas forcément une bonne
chose cette médiatisation à écouter
cette politique spectacle si on peut
appeler ça qu'il faut croire que son
avocat et ses parents s'y sent quelque
peu près tu es tu aussi à eux qu'il
faudrait poser la question quant à elle
moi je remarque que bien qu'elle soit
dans une situation très difficile
elle a exprimé le voeu que l'année du
mexique ne soit pas ne soit pas annulée
sur ce que d'autres avaient demandé
c'est de roissy on vous entend bien pas
de photos en tout cas devant le sénat
avec les parents de florence cassez
je ne veux pas demandé d'en faire alors
pour l'instant pas envie d'en faire une
je pense pas que ce soit la meilleure
solution un petit mot peut-être sur ce
que connaît aujourd'hui le monde arabe
et la crise qui est actuellement avec de
nombreuses manifestations encore libye
aujourd'hui avec des blessés et au
bahreïn
votre réaction peut-être sur cette crise
est ce que c'est aujourd'hui une
nouvelle révolution qui est en marche
à cet égard ça me paraît à certains
égards une bonne nouvelle parce que
c'est la preuve que les peuples de ces
pays aspirent à plus de justice et plus
de démocratie sans avoir fait preuve ils
ont fait preuve de beaucoup de courage
d'abord parce que ils ont été durement
réprimées ensuite ils n'ont pas du tout
versé dans la xénophobie ou le
nationalisme comme on pouvait le
redouter
au contraire je trouve qu'ils ont tenu
des propos et une attitude très mesuré
ce qu'il faut espérer c'est que
justement ces aspirations à plus de
liberté et plus de démocratie soient
satisfaites et soient pas confisqués ou
occultées par d'autres forces
un petit bout peut-être sur l'ancien
président tunisien monsieur benali qui
est aujourd'hui dans un état de santé
assez grave
est-ce que vous avez un petit mot par
rapport à l'histoire et par rapport à
monsieur ben ali pour ou opter super na
li a connu la dérive des dictateurs
c'est à dire qu il est certain qu'on
peut le créditer d'un certain nombre de
l'action tout était en faveur de son
peuple incontestablement
puis il un verset dans l'autisme dans le
favoritisme clientélisme et il a quand
même exercé enfin quelques actions
contre les droits de l'homme et une
réaction aujourd'hui il a été et est
obligé de s'exiler c'est un peu triste
pour lui mais c'est merci beaucoup
monsieur d'euros remercie d'être venu
sur notre plateau bariza khiari bonjour
sénatrice de paris
bonjour avec vous a parlé du
multiculturalisme nicolas sarkozy a dit
il ya une semaine dans son interview
qu'il a accordée à tf1 face aux français
que c'était l'échec du multiculturalisme
en france comme en allemagne ou d'autres
pays européens comme la grande-bretagne
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
l'expression qui l'employait absolument
pas la france est multiculturelle la
france est multiculturelle ça se voit
donc je ne sais pas si un échec du
multiculturalisme mais en tout cas elle
est multiculturelle c'est visible mais
moi ce qui m'inquiète plus au delà de la
formule de l'échec du multiculturalisme
qui l'employait c'est qu'il y ait un
débat qui est programmée dans l'agenda
de l'ump sur cette question et sur le
rapport à la religion et ce débat
m'inquiète énormément parce que on sent
que il y a eu à l'occasion des élections
régionales le débat sur l'identité
nationale et que là on va nous refaire
une resucée du débat sur l'identité
nationale avec emballé dans d'autres
termes qui est qui sera le
multiculturalisme le rapport aux
religions et finalement ça va être un
peu la même chose et on voit bien là que
madame le pen quelque part a gagné
puisque elle a posé les thèmes de la
campagne électorale est ce que vous avez
peur justement que cette campagne dérive
sur
le problème de la laïcité et notamment
et le problème de l'islam en france
c'est bien ça le problème
si sa dérive sur la question de la
laïcité c'est parfait la laïcité c'est
peut-être ça la majoration de la loi de
1905 la laïcité c'est la matrice qui
surplombe nos identités plurielles
je veux dire que les musulmans sont
récipiendaires
les musulmans français sont
récipiendaires des valeurs laïques comme
tout un français et comme tout français
donc elle s'applique à eux mais ce qu'on
veut en faire nicolas sarkozy j'en sais
rien en tout cas ce qu'il veut en faire
c'est une utilisation
c'est une instrumentalisation de la
religion à des fins politiques on voit
bien qu'il ya quand même un problème de
la religion de la politique laïque de la
france et on voit bien aussi sur les
mosquées
comment est ce que on fait pour que les
communautés musulmanes puissent
s'intégrer plus facilement les prières
dans les rues où on se rappelle alors
les prix avant les rues il faut quand
même pas exagérer
cela concerne les minorités c'est qu'ils
on sent bien quand il vient vérité mais
les prières dans les rues
vous savez l'occupation du domaine
public c'est du ressort de l'état
et si on voulait vraiment faire quelque
chose on pourrait le faire
les musulmans ne prient pas dans la rue
par plaisir ils prient dans la rue parce
qu'ils n'ont pas des espaces pour le
faire je pense que c'est une heure par
semaine le vendredi une heure par
semaine et que à ce moment là lol là où
il n'y a pas de mosquée là où il ya des
besoins de spiritualité des besoins de
manifester sa foi on pourrait leur
trouver des espaces c'est ce qu'il faut
faire justement la succession pour les
nourrir la situation les musulmans n'ont
pas spécialement besoin de mosquée pour
prier
ils ont besoin d'endroits propres ça
peut être un gymnase qui est mise à
disposition
ça peut être une salle mise à
disposition parce que eux ils sanctuary
l'endroit où il prit donc ce n'est pas
nécessaire que ça soit des mosquées
construites
ça peut être quand il y à des
débordements de ce genre et qu'il y a
trop de monde dans un quartier dans la
mosquée on peut très bien trouver un
local à côté et le donner donc je pense
que ce n'est pas un problème
donc vous vous avez peur quand même
il ya une vraie dérive et notamment on
parle pour les prochaines élections les
cantonales et les mois aussi bien sûr
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
vous avez peur du front national peur du
front national je pense que c'est plutôt
lui elle aurait qu'un rappeur l'ump en a
peur et c'est bien pour ça que sarkozy
ait prononcé débat sur le
multiculturalisme et sur la laïcité même
pas sur la laïcité sur le rapport aux
religions
je pense que plus que les socialistes
c'est l'ump qui a peur des marine le pen
merci vukovar et a crié merci beaucoup
je me retourne vers yves krattinger
bonjour bonjour sénateurs socialistes de
haute saône vous avez posé une question
qui était destinée à françois fillon sur
la réduction des personnels dans les
services publics c'est françois baroin
qui vous a répondu est-ce que vous étiez
satisfait de sa réponse non est ce que
vous nous expliquer pourquoi je ne suis
pas satisfait parce qu'il n'a répondu
sur aucun des sujets abordés
je suis intervenu sur trois points
l'éducation nationale qui se dégradent
34e pays pour l'encadrement au niveau de
l' ocde
nous ne pouvons pas en est chère mme
sont des derniers tout particulièrement
sur l'enseignement primaire
on nous dit que les jeunes n'apprennent
plus suffisamment à lire ou à compter
mais c'est ça à la raison profonde sur
la santé oms nous savons tous que la
situation se dégrade malheureusement
trop vite dans les hôpitaux il ya des
raisons aujourd'hui c'est une crise qui
est devant nous les gens sont très
préoccupés le service se détériore
l'hygiène fait défaut parfois il n'a pas
répondu et la même façon en ce qui
concerne la fin d'avril ce qui est l
étendard du président de la république
devient aujourd'hui un navire en
difficulté et donc
j'ai baroin a botté en touche on peut le
dire ce n'est pas très ils ont conforme
aux attentes de nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup il krattinger merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions on
ressent bien mais pas du tout satisfait
de la réponse du ministre monsieur
paroisse nous avons interrogé un petit
peu plus tôt le sénateur de belfort jean
pierre chevènement
je vous propose tout de suite les côtés
son interview monsieur chevènement ce
matin nos groupes socialistes à
boycotter l'audition de michèle alliot
marie
vous avez décidez vous de ne pas
boycotter pourquoi d'abord je n'étais
pas du tout au courant de cette décision
de boycott je vous le rappelle je
n'appartiens plus au parti socialiste
depuis 1993 j'ai constaté d'ailleurs que
de nombreux sénateurs socialistes dont
monsieur badinter était présent donc
soit ils n'ont pas brisé décision soit
ils n'étaient pas plus au courant que
moi mais nous nous sommes concentrés sur
des problèmes de fond
qu'il s'agisse des relations franco
mexicaines ou de l'aide que nous
pourrions apporter aux pays arabes de la
rive sud de la méditerranée pour qu'il
puisse relever le défi du chômage de
masse qui frappe leur jeunesse donc nous
allons privilégier le fond vous avez
senti michèle alliot-marie concentrer
sur ces dossiers écoutez je les potes
commentaire à faire sur le style des
ministres a répondu aux questions qu'on
lui ait posé seins mais ces questions
concernées le fonds est on vraiment dans
une crise entre la france et le mexique
je pense qu'il ya une grave maladresse
par rapport à
une décision de justice au mexique
concernant une personne qui semble-t-il
était incriminé pour des raisons qui au
mexique sont très préoccupantes car
l'insécurité au mexique est maximale
donc je pense qu'une bonne politique
consiste à agir efficacement et autant
que possible discrètement car ce n'est
pas forcément en faisant beaucoup de
bruit qu'on obtient les meilleurs
résultats
quelle est votre appréciation sur la
crise qui se passe dans le monde arabe
aujourd'hui la libye le bahreïn qui
après alors il ya sûrement des
distinctions à faire selon les pays
mais s'agissant de la tunisie et de
l'egypte on ne peut qu'être profondément
touchée de voir que ces peuples qui
ployait sous le joug ont été capables de
se révéler comme peuple d'affirmer leur
aspiration à la démocratie dont on
finissait par douter et je pense que
c'est une très bonne nouvelle que de
voir que dans le monde arabe entre la
dictature et l'intégrisme
il y as place aussi pour la démocratie
en tout cas pour l'inspiration la
démocratie est ce que moi je suggérais
habana mme alliot marie
c'est que nous regardions comment nous
pourrions étendre nos systèmes de
garantie investissements de façon à
favoriser plutôt des délocalisations
maghreb que dans des pays à très bas
coûts en asie de façon à les stabiliser
comment nous pourrions offrir des
marchés mieux protégés aux produits de
ces pays comment nous pouvons les aider
à diversifier leur économie à donner des
emplois à leurs jeunes qui aujourd'hui
en sont trop souvent privés nicolas
sarkozy veut une loi sur eux en tout cas
a dit que c'était l'échec du
multiculturalisme en france et peut-être
revoir la loi de 1905 est ce que vous
êtes là
accord avec la position du président de
la république mais je ne comprends pas
très bien ce que veut dire le présent un
public il a le le premier parlé de
préfet musulman
il me paraît souvent aller dans le sens
du de la complaisance à l'égard des
communautarismes les plus variés
musulman juif catholique
c'est lui qui explique le curé était au
dessus de l'instituteur tout ça ne tient
pas la route
je pense que la france est une
république une et indivisible comme on
disait
mais en tout cas avec des valeurs qui
sont des valeurs républicaines qui
s'applique à tous et je connais mon nom
à tous sans distinction d'origine est de
confession c'est d'accepter la loi
républicaine c'est tout et pour le reste
s'agissant de la religion ou des
affinités culturelles chez le domaine de
la liberté
monsieur le ministre est ce que c'est un
point sur lequel vous pourriez être
candidat en 2012
on sait que vous vous laissiez entendre
il ya peu
je ne le serai pas principalement sur ce
point là je suis très attaché ça
pourrait s que ça pourrait vous inciter
à être candidat écoute je suis très
attaché à la république à ce qu'elle
signifie je crois à la modernité de son
message je pense que aujourd'hui en
europe il faudrait redonner un élan à
notre nation est d'ailleurs à toutes les
nations parce que je crois que l'europe
doit se faire avec les nations et
passant elle est par conséquent ça ce
serait un argument qui pourrait me
motiver pour l'instant pas question a je
n'osais pas dit ça 1 c'est une réflexion
est en cours ça chemine oui disent que
c'est une décision grave importante et
si je la prends c'est parce que je
considérais que c'est mon devoir
certains moments pour faire bouger les
lignes pour élever le niveau du débat
pour redonner un avenir à la france
merci beaucoup monsieur chevènement
d'être venu sur le plateau de public
sénat voilà c'était la réponse de jean
pierre chevènement merci de nous avoir
suivis pour on refait la séance ne
manquez pas nos rendez vous à 19h le
journal de michel grossiord à 22 heures
le rendez vous avec sonia mabrouk tout
de suite vous retrouvez la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale bercy
à tous